let's shift to the second topic here so
the the interest rates are going up uh
here's video of the Federal Reserve
announcing that uh yeah they're going up
25 basis points Federal Reserve raising
by 25 basis points to a new range of
four and a half to 475 this is the
eighth straight hike by the Federal
Reserve since March up by a quarter to
four and a half to 475. the Federal
Reserve sees ongoing increases as
appropriate so that phrase that some
thought might come out remains in the
FED is still in route to a level that
calls a sufficiently restrictive level
of the funds rate one little bit of
dovish commentary here says inflation as
he's somewhat however it says it Still
Remains elevated
Vivek give me uh inflation 101 here uh
for the people that that don't pay that
much attention to this stuff 25 basis
points okay it's the eighth hike in a
row why does this matter why why should
people actually care about this yeah I
mean let's just zoom out I mean at a 50
000 foot level I think we shouldn't and
the FED is a joke but we'll we'll come
back to that later just in terms of the
present of what we're talking about for
about a decade and a half following the
2008 financial crisis the Federal
Reserve pumped a lot of money into the
system they used a wide range of tools
fancy sounding tool kits to do it but
the bottom line is they pumped a lot of
money into the system they did it with
Reckless disregard to what the long run
consequences of that would be there was
a myth that somehow doing that would
graduate from the old rules of finance
and stop us from placing an inflationary
crisis turns out we do phrase you know
rampant inflation now over the last year
this was of course predictable though
they pretend like it wasn't it was of
course exacerbated by other forms of
government spending exacerbated by
shooting ourselves in the foot with
respect to energy self-sufficiency which
then has other cost drivers but the
federal reserve's actions over the last
decade and a half were a big part of it
if you ski on artificial snow for a long
time you're in trouble when the
artificial snow machine turns off so
what happens now is that because we're
facing inflation the Federal Reserve has
to hike rates we've seen this movie
before Paul volcker had to do it in the
you know in under the Reagan
Administration and otherwise but right
now we faced a little bit of a double
whammy because it's a little bit
different than volcker did it under
Reagan you at least had okay when rates
go up that cools off the economy a
little bit rains in inflation but that
was against the backdrop of reaganite
Reform like cutting taxes like
deregulating the administrative state
right now we have a double whammy
because unfortunately now the Federal
Reserve has to have its hand Force to
raise rates to fight inflation against
the backdrop of a Biden Administration
that doesn't have the the pro-growth
agenda that the Reagan Administration
did so I think that that's a little bit
of a double whammy which makes this a
little bit more painful potentially at
least a little bit more painful than
last time around when you had the Volker
Reagan complementary combo at least here
it's it's too too negatives pointing in
the same direction from an economic
perspective one is by the Federal
Reserve cooling the economy but the
other is the Biden administration's
policies are doing the economy no favors
at the same time if you'd like more sane
takes on our insane World check out our
direct message clips playlist and if you
want to watch more full episodes of our
live round tables watch our round tables
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell